we are less than a week away from
kicking off season two
of the drew barrymore show and our big
premier guest will be none other than
jennifer aniston
i mean
i could not be more excited to talk to
her
we actually were in a movie together
he's just not that into you
and we have a very good friend in common
mr adam sandler
and i gotta ask her about the morning
show because oh it is just one of my
favorites but everything she does is my
favorite she's jennifer aniston
plus
while we're in my hometown of los
angeles i'll be taking you all on a tour
of the places that mean most to me
the house i grew up in
my very first apartment at 14
and
i'm revisiting some other places that
might come as a surprise that i'm
actually revealing them but i mean them
to be an invitation to you
so that we can embrace everything that's
happened in our lives
and be proud of where it has brought us
it's happening all next week on season
two of the drew barrymore show
see you soon
[Music]